- [Blonde man] Oh, man.
- [Man in hat] (loud sigh)
- Work today is tough.
- I know.
- I just need a smoke break.
- Tell me about it, man.
Cigarettes. (laughs)
I remember when I used to smoke those...
yesterday, I got this new e-cig.
- I don't know how I feel about e-cigs,
you know, I just think
they're kinda weird.
Then you, like, charge them in a computer
and just, I just don't like it.
I mean, if I had to charge
anything in the computer,
it'd probably be my new vape pen.
- Vapes, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know, you can just, like,
bring these into any kind
of food establishment
and just smoke inside, they're great.
- Vapes actually remind
me of my portable hookah.
- I don't know, that just seems
kind of inconvenient to me.
- I just carry this pretty much anywhere
and smoke it anywhere.
- You know, I've got this thing that's
been in my family actually
for, like, 27 years or so.
- Looks like a snorkel.
- [Blonde man] Yeah.
- It is a snorkel.
- You do that and, you
know, it's kinda clean.
- You probably haven't
seen this one before,
this is the hot box.
It's really perfect.
- You bring that places, like,
you're on a date at the
movies and you're just
gonna bring that in, like,
the trunk of your car?
- [Man in hat] Yeah, I mean, if you wanna
a good smoke session this is what you do.
- Do you actually have a Steve?
Yeah, Steve is great.
We just kinda do this.
(loud exhale)
It's really good,
he just filters out the
toxins and just takes a drag.
Let's do another one, man.
(loud exhale)
Yeah, it's really awesome.
- That's nice,
but have you ever tried
smoking outta yourself?
(melancholy piano music)
(uptempo electronic music)